claire marin vous êtes philosophe et vos
travaux tout au moins dans leur ancrage
académique se porte sur la maladie comme
symptômes du vivant autrement dit vous
partez de la maladie pour interroger le
vivant car la maladie et l'expression et
le révélateur du vivant c'est parce
qu'on est vivant qu'on est malade ou
comme le disait mon thème que vous citez
tu ne meurt pas de ce que tu es malade
tu meurs de ce que tu es vivant or le
vivant est un train sacrement violent
destructeur voire autodestructeur
pourtant aujourd'hui on a une forte
tendance à l'occulter et même au
contraire il est un peu porté au nu
alors notamment à travers évidemment la
pensée écologique et on assiste à un
double paradoxe d'un côté la vie est
sacralisée malgré les violences qu'elle
recèle et de l'autre la santé et
sacralisée également comme si elle était
justement le synonyme de la vie comme si
la maladie devait être reléguée dans
l'ombre et dans les hôpitaux
alors pourquoi la santé est-elle devenue
une maladie obsessionnelle pour
reprendre l'expression de Georges
kanguilhem alors
c'est vrai que notre notre rapport à la
maladie et à sa visibilité à changer
c'est lié notamment évidemment en
progrès médicaux mais aussi sans doute
au changement des structures familiales
ou on est moins moins proche de ce qui
vieillissent de ce qu'on voit malade
donc la maladie et c'est notre luxe est
devenu une forme
de
moments qu'on identifie peut-être à la
fin de la vie on a d'une certaine
manière un peu
on s'est défav familiarisé de la maladie
alors qu'elle reste toujours très
fréquente qu'on souffre de nouvelles
maladies qui sont liées à notre mode de
vie et en ce sens je crois que la
période du
confinement ou du covid a été assez
révélatrice parce que
on s'est rendu compte de tous ceux qui
étaient malades
sans le dire de tous ceux pour qui la
maladie invisible de toutes ces
vulnérabilités et on a vu à quel point
oui le les êtres vivants sont
vulnérables et que la dynamique de la
vie c'est d'être créatrice mais aussi
d'être déstructrice ou d'être une
épreuve pour le sujet être vivant c'est
aussi éprouvant et pourquoi on l'occulte
ça
parce que c'est quelque chose qui est
angoissant tout simplement c'est notre
manière de nous divertir de ce qui fait
partie de notre finitude d'être sensible
et d'être donc d'être potentiellement
touché par la douleur par la destruction
ou la moindrement du corps donc c'est un
oubli qui est lié au divertissement au
sens parce qu'elle vient du terme mais
c'est aussi une occultation qui est liée
finalement
à la civilisation contemporaine c'est ce
que vous désirez on la voit plus la
maladie on la voit plus la mort elle
n'est plus visible au sens où dans
l'espace public on pourrait ou même à
l'intérieur de la maisonnée on pourrait
la rendre visible comment faire pour
renouer avec cette évidence de la
maladie sans non plus sombrer dans une
forme de tristesse ou Denis ou je ne
sais quoi alors je crois que les choses
changent un peu d'avoir parce que les
patients deviennent visibles parce qu'on
reconnaît aussi la valeur de leur
expérience
ça devient de plus en plus banal de
parler de sa maladie envie de révéler la
maladie dont on souffre donc il y a
peut-être quelque chose qui est en train
de se transformer
il y a juste un billet qui me semble
inquiétant c'est quand la maladie
devient fait de nous une espèce de héros
ou quand elle devient le centre même de
notre existence
là c'est un biais qu'on voit par exemple
dans le vocabulaire qui est parfois
utilisé dans
c'est très clair aux États-Unis on va
parler de combattants on va parler de
guerre contre la maladie
toutes ces métaphores elle
elle passe à côté je crois de ce que
c'est que l'expérience de la maladie
c'est aussi reconnaître
qu'on est affaibli qu'on est vulnérable
qu'on dépend des autres et c'est pas une
humiliation d'être dans une relation de
dépendance ou d'interdépendance donc la
maladie en tant qu'elle brise l'espèce
de fantasme de l'individu autonome
elle était un peu dérangeante pour une
société qui aime cet individualisme un
peu glorifié mais je crois
qu'aujourd'hui on commence à à réagir
contre cette atomisation et cette
solitude en fait des sujets parce qu'on
voit que ça ce que ça produit comme
violence
dans les EHPAD par exemple mais aussi la
violence qu'on impose à des familles
qu'on laisse seule avec des des enfants
lourdement handicapés le fait que la
société manque de ces structures
d'accompagnement et de banalisation du
handicap ou de la maladie
le domaine du travail
ou dans le domaine social ou vraiment
rien n'est facile l'été pour les malades
et les personnes qui souffrent de
handicap ça c'est
l'élément qu'il faut qu'il faut repenser
et qu'il faut retravailler je pense et
comment arriver à changer la vision de
la maladie que ce soit du coup niche
héroïsé à travers les métaphores que
vous rappelez de du combattant ou
effectivement quand on est malade on n'a
pas le choix ni de l'autre côté ce
discours de la performance ce discours
de la réussite ou la maladie ou ceux qui
qui seraient plus lents ceux qui n'y
arriverait pas son contraire relégué du
côté de l'ombre et du silence comment
changer les mentalités je pense que ça
peut commencer très tôt c'est à dire par
une plus grande intégration
dès l'école d'enfants qui ont des
difficultés qui peuvent être liées à un
état du corps une pathologie à partir du
moment où la maladie devient familière
elle est moins inquiétante je crois et
puis on se rend compte aussi de ce qu'on
peut faire en étant malade donc c'est
pas parce qu'on est malade qu'on a perdu
toutes ses compétences donc en ce sens
là il y a peut-être aussi une
méconnaissance qui
peut être travaillé dans des lieux de
sociabilité et je pense que dès
l'enfance on voit bien que des enfants
qui sont habitués à jouer avec des
enfants porteurs de handicap
ils vont s'adapter quand ils le font ils
vont être assez solidaires plutôt
généreux sans idéaliser les choses mais
ça peut très bien fonctionner si on a
des bâtiments et adaptés et ce qui est
un vrai problème quand même aujourd'hui
et si on a aussi un personnel qui est
rassuré et qui est un peu formé à
comprendre et à accepter les différences
que les enfants malades ou les
adolescents ou les salariés de
l'entreprise peuvent les différents anti
peuvent souffrir alors la politique la
formation l'éducation mais également le
rôle de la philosophie parce que la
philosophie c'est toujours intéressé aux
soins aux soins de l'âme tout au moins
elle a un peu relégué la question de la
maladie
à d'autres disciplines et c'est
peut-être la médecine qui s'en est
emparée évidemment avec le plus de
légitimité mais ça pose également un
problème que peut la philosophie
aujourd'hui comment comment peut-elle
réintervenir dans dans ce débat et
comment peut-elle reprendre un peu du
terrain sur la médecine je crois que
c'est une question de dialogue avec la
médecine
ce dialogue on envoie la fécondité par
exemple quand on lit les textes de
kanguel qui étaient à la fois philosophe
et médecin et qui pose finalement un peu
les bases d'une philosophie du soin déjà
dans son analyse
c'est aussi à la psychologie ou à la
psychanalyse que la philosophie du soin
va emprunter donc elle se nourrit à la
fois d'une d'une philosophie du corps
qu'on trouve dans la Phénoménologie au
XXème siècle mais qui sont racines en
fait sans doute
plus en avant dans l'histoire de de la
philosophie le souci du corps finalement
il est déjà chez Montaigne que vous
citiez tout à l'heure
et là où la philosophie a un rôle à
jouer c'est dans l'identification
des vécus douloureux c'est-à-dire dans
le fait d'ajouter un souci de la
subjectivité du sujet de la personne
dans le soin médical et le soin n'étant
pas réduit à la thérapie c'est à dire
que
il y a toute une dimension de
l'expérience du malade qui sort
évidemment du cabinet qui sort de
l'hôpital et on peut continuer à se
sentir malade ou avoir peur de retomber
malade même si on est officiellement
biologiquement guéri donc le véhicule de
la maladie en fait est dans la mesure où
il s'étend bien au-delà des sphères où
il est traité il interroge
nécessairement et c'est là que la
philosophie un rôle à jouer l'identité
du sujet la manière dont l'épreuve de la
maladie le transforme voire parfois le
détruit ou le démoli on emploie parfois
le terme d'effondrement et je pense que
ça correspond à un vécu subjectif très
fort
et la philosophie peut être là pour
accompagner celui qui justement a
l'impression d'être dans un dénuement et
aussi une forme de solitude parce que ce
que fait la maladie c'est de mettre à
mal et parfois de briser les liens qui
jouait en rôle important dans la manière
dont on s'identifier jusqu'à leur et de
la construction de soi et tout à fait
bien sûr
isolé mais également relation alors vous
montrez bien les ambivalences à la fois
de la vie qui porte en elle une violence
mais également justement du soin on a
parlé du Caire de la philosophie du soin
qui qui prend une importance de plus en
plus considérable il y a juste titre
aujourd'hui néanmoins vous montrer aussi
que le soin peut receler une forme de
violence est-ce qu'on peut parler de
cette tension en fait qui est inhérente
aux soins oui il y a nécessairement dans
dans les techniques thérapeutiques des
gestes qui font violences qui sont une
forme de violation de l'intégrité ou la
sacralité intime du corps donc il y a
des violences qui sont sans doute
nécessaires et les médecins ont ce droit
c'est ce que dit Paul Valéry dans son
discours chirurgien les médecins ont le
droit de faire ce que aucun d'entre nous
n'a le droit de faire c'est à dire
ouvrir un corps
et ce geste là
il prend aussi un sens violent s'il est
mal accompagné
la mise à nu du patient au sens littéral
comme au sens symbolique puisque
quand on est soigné on est amené à
raconter des choses de soi qui peuvent
être très intimes
cette mise à nu elle peut être vécue
comme humiliante il y a des gestes très
simples où il y a même des objets très
banal qui peuvent être ressentis comme
humiliant des positions
le simple fait d'être de ne pas être à
la hauteur du patient c'est-à-dire de le
regarder de haut quand il est allongé
sur son lit donc
il y a des violences qui sont parfois
absolument pas consciente je crois qui
ne sont pas volontaires mais entre
parenthèses l'idée d'un sadisme qui
existe dans toutes les professions qui
existent aussi ici mais en dehors de ça
il y a des que des ressentis de violence
qui sans doute pourraient disparaître
quand on réfléchit
en se plaçant dans la peau du patient et
c'est ce qui se passe dans certaines
facs de médecine ou les étudiants en
médecine en fait sont confrontés à des
équivalents de jeux drôles avec des
acteurs de théâtre qui finalement les
mettent un peu face à des situations où
malgré eux ils pourraient les étudiants
en médecine finalement
dire quelque chose de violent ou
d'agressif et c'est tout ce qui est
pensé en ce moment la question de
l'annonce comment on annonce une
pathologie sévère
ou une maladie avec laquelle il faudra
vivre toute sa vie tous ces éléments là
de langage de langage corporel de
relations et d'endroits aussi
à quel endroit ça se passe
avec qui à
moment est-ce qu'il faut pas répéter des
choses qui seront pas comprises parce
qu'on est sidérés par le diagnostic qui
vient d'être énoncé donc tout ça ça
mérite d'être réfléchi pour que
l'approche médicale soit aussi une
approche de soins une approche globale
il est à noter dans les facs de médecine
vraiment les philosophie la médecine
travail de plus en plus ensemble alors
on a mis une image de radio
précisément un peu en lien avec ce que
vous dites savoir cette relation médecin
patient qui a aussi partie d'une
certaine représentation du corps du
corps mécanisé du corps machine dissocié
de la personne en quelque sorte fin de
cette espèce de dualisme ou de
dichotomie entre l'âme et le corps et
c'est vrai que la technicité la
technique le progrès technique en
médecine ne favorise pas nécessairement
une approche globale puisque lorsque le
patient peut être découpé en morceaux on
peut être scanner ou peut être
photographié c'est vrai que ça n'aide
pas à une vision beaucoup plus humanisée
peut-être
des supports qu'on utilisait autrefois
c'était les écorchés on s'a dit quelque
chose en fait c'est à dire vraiment on
ouvre ce qui est d'habitude d'abord être
un et pas couper ou diviser et puis on
regarde à l'intérieur et puis on voit de
la matière c'est à dire là on a une
image c'est ce que dit certains
étudiants en médecine on a une image qui
est plane qui est lisse
le patient idéal il est compliant dans
le vocabulaire médical c'est-à-dire il
va être propre il va comprendre tout ce
qu'on lui dit il va faire ce qu'on lui
demande de faire et va suivre son
traitement à la lettre etc ce patient
n'existe pas donc les images en fait
elles faussent la relation à la fois
elles font elles font écran d'une
certaine manière on passe par les images
avant d'atteindre le patient
et c'est pour ça que je crois que
il faut que une relation qui soit
humaine et humanisante doit être
préalable à la confrontation de l'image
mais la logique
d'un temps de plus en plus accéléré la
logique de la rentabilité à l'hôpital
qui est une pure aberration
font que effectivement ce temps-là qui
est du temps de l'écoute du patient et
de son ressenti souvent est réduit parce
que on va aller plus rapidement vers le
geste technique qui lui est aussi
nécessaire mais qui ne prendra son pour
le patient que s'il est un peu
accompagné et expliqué
la technique est le progrès technique
vont même jusqu'à favoriser un
imaginaire transhumaniste qui va
complètement l'opposé de ce que de ce
que vous développez là l'idée d'un homme
qui serait réellement augmenté mais
augmenter non pas par son humanité ou
son cœur ou sa ou sa compassion ou que
sais-je mais par la technique quoi oui
mais je crois que une lecture un peu
réaliste de du moment présent c'est de
voir qu'il faut que l'homme soit
simplifié et pas augmenté il va falloir
réduire nos besoins nos habitudes nos
manières de vivre et que ce délire
toujours plus juste des mesures ça
pourrait dire cette hubrique de la
technique avec tous les fantasmes
de puissance et d'éternité ou de
quasi-éternité ou de jeunesse que
transhumanisme véhicule
ces idées elles sont déjà obsolètes
elles sont complètement déconnectées
de la vie qui doit devenir la nôtre
c'est-à-dire avec un retour à des
éléments plus modestes plus vivant plus
biologique
et en ce sens j'ai l'impression que ces
modèles ne fonctionnent plus que pour
ceux qui sont déjà hors sol d'une
certaine façon facile de l'autre côté
mais juste pour revenir doucement à
l'action de l'image je crois que c'est
intéressant justement cette médiation
par l'image pour se découvrir soi-même
enfin c'est un soin un peu particulier
parce que c'est un soi matériel quoi en
quelque sorte au fond est-ce que on peut
pas étendre cette cette idée au-delà
même de l'hôpital savoir qu'on a besoin
aujourd'hui l'image pour pour attester
d'une forme de réalité je sais pas on a
besoin de se prendre en selfie pour pour
se rendre compte qu'on a vécu quelque
chose au lieu d'être dans une forme
d'immédiate ou de présence à soi-même
est-ce que c'est pas quelque chose de
global et qui ne touche pas seulement
l'hôpital si si sans doute cette cette
ben oui ce qui fait écran c'est-à-dire à
la fois qui peut nous donner
l'impression de nous protéger qu'on peut
avoir l'illusion de maîtriser
là où en fait évidemment ça nous échappe
beaucoup et puis le les choses se
renversent c'est comme dans dans des
formes de narcissisme c'est-à-dire que
le
l'image finalement on va prendre le
dessus sur nous jusqu'à engendrer
puisqu'on parle de maladie des
pathologies de de représentation fausse
ou de distorsion de l'image de soi donc
on voit comment l'usage
de filtre fait perdre le l'image de soi
véritable avec tout ce qu'elle a de
vivant d'irréguliers d'asymétrie mais
c'est ça le vivant c'est pas quelque
chose qui qui pourrait être justement
dessiner par un ordinateur ou alors
justement est-ce que la douleur sans
vouloir la sacraliser évidemment mais ce
que justement il n'est pas aussi un
petit rappel de cette question du vivant
qui n'est pas exportable vers uniquement
une mise en image ou je sais pas où une
perfection par la chirurgie esthétique
ou je sais pas mais enfin l'idée que la
douleur finalement nous ramène à la
vulnérabilité à notre corps propre oui
elle est elle est un signe de justement
cette cette corporalité du sujet de sa
sensibilité et puis évidemment
toute une vie de douleur
c'est insupportable mais certains sont
dans cette épreuve là
mais la douleur c'est aussi le contraste
enfin il y a aussi cette idée là que il
y a des douleurs qui sont heureuses si
j'ai couru un marathon et peut-être
c'est fictif oui je vais souffrir mais
dans cette douleur il y a aussi parfois
de manière qui a une bonne fatigue une
fatigue heureuse comme dit Merleau-Ponty
il y a aussi une douleur que je surmonte
parce qu'elle s'inscrit dans un but qui
est le mien si je fais de la danse
classique je vais prouver des douleurs
assez fortes à cause des postures des
positions etc mais la douleur qui est
subie qui est infligé qui s'inscrit pas
dans un but qui la dépasse elle est
vaine et elle est insupportable pour
cela scandaleuse elle est tout à fait
scandaleuse alors on a on a un
autoportrait de rang musique qui lui a
connu la douleur pour le coup
et qu'il a peint de manière merveilleuse
mais il n'y a pas que ça on voit dans
ces dans ces tableaux je crois que c'est
un peintre que vous affectionnez ouais
tout à fait et ce qui est intéressant
pour faire le lien avec la radio
précédente c'est que il peint aussi
des cadavres dans les camps de
concentration et quand on est loin du
tableau et qu'on ne sait pas
ça a l'air effectivement d'être de la
matière ça a l'air d'être des bouts de
bois dépouiller blanchies avec en
arrière fond vaguement une forêt et donc
il y a cette réification en fait du
corps qui est aussi la marque des des
bourreaux qui ne respectent pas la
sacralité du corps du défunt qui ne
l'enterre pas mais juste qu'il
l'entassent donc réduire un homme à la
matérialité de son corps c'est aussi ce
que font les les pires idéologies
pour revenir à la vieillesse qu'on a
évoqué au début et qui en effet
et parfois identifié à une maladie
via ce qui a une double actualité à
travers la réforme des retraites et la
question de la fin de vie
comment vous vous positionnez par
rapport à cette question de la fin de
vie
alors sur cette sur cette question
disons que ma réflexion est encore en
cours
et
d'un point de vue personnel je
j'aurais tendance à penser que on
devrait pouvoir choisir le moment où on
met fin à sa vie mais ce qui m'a
beaucoup troublée c'était une discussion
avec des soignants québécois
qui pratiquait l'accompagnement de
personnes qui qui souhaitaient mourir et
certains d'entre eux disaient les gens
qui vont mourir
donc avec des pratiques de suicides
assister aux euthanasie leur pathologie
la plus grande c'est la solitude c'est à
dire que s'ils étaient bien entourés
s'ils étaient moins seuls peut-être que
leur envie de mourir serait moins vive
et n'irait pas jusqu'à cette décision là
donc je pense qu'il faut il faut il faut
bien distinguer en fait dans la manière
dont on aborde
la possibilité de cet accompagnement ça
peut être un soin un soin
presque simplement humain parce que la
situation dans laquelle se trouve le
patient est insupportable intolérable
elle est invivable au sens propre du
terme en terme de souffrance
psychique et physique et dans ce cas ça
peut être un geste humain de mettre fin
à ses souffrances
et par ailleurs il faut comprendre en
fait si dans sa souffrance il y a pas
des choses qui sont encore de notre
ressort et qui pourrait diminuer cette
envie de mettre fin à sa vie
alors pour parler de choses un petit peu
plus gaie on parle de la fin mais bon la
fin c'est un sujet de grande importance
et en effet qui convoque toutes les
dimensions politiques médicales
affective parler de solitude qui est
l'un des grands mots de notre société et
vos comptes plutôt les débuts puisque
vous avez écrit un livre qui qui traite
des débuts
racontez-nous quelques débuts joyeux
quelques débuts c'est
la naissance par exemple c'est le début
de quelque chose qui sera à la fois très
joyeux et très douloureux aussi
douloureux et épuisant mais ce qui
m'intéressait dans cette question des
débuts c'est l'intensité c'est il me
semble que si on a la nostalgie des
débuts c'est parce qu'il y a quelque
chose dans l'intensité du sentiment de
vivre qui est quelque chose qui nous
ranime c'est le retour d'un élan
c'est une forme de ponctuation ou de
rythme de l'existence donc quand quelque
chose débute que ce soit la vie d'un
enfant que ce soit une nouvelle relation
qu'on s'adonne à une nouvelle activité
quelle qu'elle soit il y a quelque chose
de ce retour de l'élan que je trouve
toujours à la fois émouvant et
surprenant y compris quand on pense que
ça n'arrivera plus donc en fait la
question des débuts elle croise aussi
des thé qui sont parfois tragiques
comment on peut connaître de nouveaux
débuts alors qu'on a pu croire à cause
de son âge à cause de la catastrophe
convient de vivre que jamais on
retrouvera cette élan ce désir d'être en
vie de nouer des liens ce sentiment
amoureux avec cette intensité donc il y
a quelque chose de toujours un peu
miraculeux dans le fait de revenir à la
vie quand on a l'impression de d'en être
radicalement sorti merci Clara pour ces
derniers mots qui qui nous donne de
l'espoir merci